- Tell you one thing,
when the unsullied
make it to Westeros,
they're going to
annihilate people.
- Wait, wait, wait
dude. Hold up.
- It's going to be crazy
- First of all, slow down.
Second of all, I'm
not up to that yet.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
- Oh yeah.
- I didn't know that. I figured.
- I will erase it.
- Ta-dam, la-zam. I'm like,
you know what I'm saying?
- But Jordan, right now,
but right now you must listen to
how this white dude is
talking to Black people.
- Get out of my face with
your Tommy Bahama ass.
I'm trying to make some
beats, yo. I'm a DJ.
- No.
- I want that pussy
on my chain wax, son.
- He wants the pussy
on the chain wax.
- That's pathetic,
that's pathetic.
- What's up girl.
- Dude, he's walking this way.
He's totally walking this way.
- I can't, I can't, I can't.
- Just go with it,
dude. Just go with it.
- Hey! Hey, how's it going?
Key and Peele, right?
- Good.
- So stoked you guys are
here. Thanks for coming out.
You guys rock. Awesome.
Yo Kevin! Let me
get some Red Vines!
(quiet music)
- Want to get out of here?
- Yep.
(beat boxing)
(upbeat music)
- Excuse me, pardon me.
Hey player.
- How you doing, man?
- Hey, can I make a request?
- Sure, man. What
are you looking for?
- Hey man. Hook a brother up
with something old school.
- Oh yeah. All
right. Word, okay.
What you looking
for? Biggie, Tupac?
- Biggie, Tupac?
Come on, man, that's too new.
I'm talking about
that old school, man.
You know what I'm talking about.
- Oh, but I thought I did.
Maybe like Wu-Tang Clan?
- Wu-Tang Clan.
Come on, man, those
fool just came out.
Hook a brother up with
some of that old school.
- Oh, okay. What-
I don't know what you're
looking for, man. What N.W.A?
- N.W.A? Come on, man. What do
I look like, a kid out there?
Talking about the N.W.A.,
fo shizzle my nizzle,
criss-cross apple sauce,
Who's the Boss? Tony Danza,
at a loft. I don't know it.
All right. I'm talking
about that old school.
- Okay. You know what?
That's my bad, old
man. All right.
We going to take
it back. All right.
I'm going to bust out some
Run-D.M.C. for you right now.
- Run-D.M.C.?
(laughing)
Come on, man.
I don't know about none
of this Run-D.M.C. oh,
wouldn't want to be
ya, onomatopoeia,
grab a donkey by the
toe, give him gonorrhea.
I don't know it. All right.
All I know is some old school.
If you can't give it to me,
you can't give it to me.
- Come on man.
Run-D.M.C. is old school.
Well can you name a group?
- You the DJ, man.
I ain't trying to tell
you how to do your job.
- Grandmaster Flash?
- Oh man, Grandmaster Flash.
You sounding like
a kid yourself,
talking about Grandmaster Flash,
to the um bop
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo,
that don't stop the boogey
to the bang bang boogie,
the up chuck. Why are people
talking about up chuck?
- Sugarhill Gang?
- Brother, how we
end up in Candyland?
- Know what man,
if you want some old school
then you come back here
and find it yourself.
I'm going on break
(upbeat music)
- All right then. Get myself
back here, right in here.
See what's going on back here.
What we got? What we got?
Let's see. Nope, Nope,
Nope, Nope, Nope, Nope
Nope, Nope, Nope,
Nope, Nope, Nope Nope.
Ah, there, now we talking.
(swing music)
- What the (beep) is happening?
(upbeat music)
- [DJ] It's Friday
night. Make some noise!
(cheering)
Throw your hands in the air!
(upbeat music)
If you cool, like a
pimp, put your hands up!
If you cool like a
'Cause you're a natural
pimp, put your hands up!
If you own a bunch of
woman, put your hands up!
(upbeat music)
If your going to hit it all
night, put your hands up!
If you maintain an
erection for 12 hours,
put your hands up!
Without the benefit of
Viagra, puts your hands up!
(upbeat music)
If you a real live
player, put your hands up!
If you abuse women's
trust, put your hands up!
If you treat her the like
objects, put your hands up!
(upbeat music)
If you a real live
gangster, put your hands up!
If you kill other people,
put your hands up!
(upbeat music)
If you the biggest boss
here, put your hands up!
(upbeat music)
If you run an actual drug
ring, put your hands up!
(upbeat music)
If you just realized
that you're full of shit,
put your hands up!
(cheering)
- It's Joey Blows
in the morning!
- Yo, Joey Blows
here on 101.2 K-
- And Meatball!
- Everybody, man. We still
tripping on that last segment.
But that was crazy up in here-
- (indistinct) crazy though.
- Wardrobe malfunction.
(laughing)
- Y'all are crazy. I
can't take you no more.
- Like y'all dirty,
but she's crazy.
- Would you do that Meatball?
- Look, man, I grew up in
the hood. All right. So no.
(laughing)
- He would want to
but he can't do it,
'cause of that fat ass.
(shouting)
- Why y'all always clowning
on Meatball? Meatball.
- You brought it up.
- For real though.
- Y'all love some (indistinct)
- Y'all two got to stop playing.
- Meatball!
- Playa Jay with
me and Meatball!
- Meatball.
- This is the top of the hour,
I'm Joey Blows,
we'll be right back.
(cheering)
(quiet background radio chatter)
- [Announcer] KBeats 101.3.
(shouting)
(upbeat music)
- Well, tonight we going to
party 'til the party don't stop
and the party don't stop
because it keeps on going
nonstop, going to
party all night.
Going to keep this party going,
'cause the party won't stop.
It's been two straight days
and the party still going.
Two, three, four,
five, six, seven days,
till it's Friday again and
then the party keeps going.
Party all night, 'cause
it's an all night party.
Friday night, 9:00 PM. Hop
in the car, call my friends.
Drinks in the back,
girls up front,
going to a party,
setting them texts.
Cell phone rings, Ipad,
Facebook, party time.
Skin tight jeans, Friday
nights, dance, dance, dance,
'cause tonight we going out
and we ain't coming back.
Cause the party won't
stop, it will go all night.
Friday night, every night,
the party's going down,
down, down, down, down,
down, down, down, down, down.
New York city, LA, Chicago,
Houston, Philly, San Diego,
Phoenix, Austin,
Fort Worth, Boston,
Memphis, Denver,
Portland, Vegas, Tucson,
Fresno, Akron, Tampa,
Pittsburgh, Newark, Plano,
Lincoln, Love it, Durham,
Salem, Dayton city,
city, city, city.
'Cause tonight we going out
and we ain't coming back.
'Cause the party won't
stop and will go all night.
Friday night, every night,
the party's going down,
down, down, down down,
down, down, down, down.
New York city, LA, Chicago,
Houston, Philly, San Diego,
Phoenix, Austin,
Fort Worth, Boston,
Memphis, Denver,
Portland, Vegas,
Tucson, Fresno, Akron,
Tampa, Pittsburgh
Newark, Plano, Lincoln, love it,
Durham, Salem, Dayton city,
city, city, city, city!
Now, we're going to keep
going 'til the break of,
break of dawn. then we'll just
keep partying all day long.
Hot girls, music, dancing,
and bikinis, damn it.
Phones, party, party, party
party, party,
party, party, party.
(gun shooting)
(upbeat music)
So tonight we going to party
'till the party don't stop.
- So I have finished
the kitchen.
I have finished my bedroom.
I finished the office
and I'm just wrapping
up the living room.
- Okay. I'll get pack a lacking.
- I love it. I love it.
- Mind if I put on some music?
- I do not. I do not.
- All right.
I got this new Dubstep.
- Dubstep. What is that?
I don't know what that is.
- Oh dude, you're
going to love it.
- Oh cool, cool man.
(beeping)
(Dubstep music)
I like this.
- Wait for the drop.
- I'm sorry, the drop?
(beat dropping)
(Dubstep music)
What is happening?
- What?
- What is this?
- I can't hear you!
(Dubstep music stops)
- What is that?
- The music?
- I'm sorry, is that music?
- Oh yeah. Dude, that's the
Dubstep, man. That's my jam.
- Well, it's a little
loud and disorienting
and you're being a little
rough with my things.
- Rough with- Dude,
your stuff is fine.
- Why am I sweating so much?
- Because you're feeling it.
- Is that a good thing?
- Yes.
Come on man. Just
give it another shot.
- Okay. Okay. I will.
(Dubstep music)
(Dubstep music stops)
- Whoa! Dude. You're
totally jacking flow out.
- Dude, your nose is
bleeding and so is mine.
- Awesome.
- It doesn't really
seem like music to me.
- Okay. Wow. Wally,
getting a little bit old.
- No, don't do that. Come on.
- No, didn't realize
that. Okay. Um.
Yeah, what would you
rather listen to?
I can hook you up with some
Hootie and the Blowfish.
If that's your-
- Oh, that's funny.
- Is that good? Want
some Color Me Badd?
- You know what? Go
ahead. I don't care.
I see what you're doing.
Go ahead and play it.
I don't care, because
I'm not that old.
I can get into it. Okay?
Let's just get this
stuff packed, play it.
(Dubstep music)
(yelling)
(glass shattering)
(car alarm ringing)
I think I'm getting it!
- Yeah!
(laughing)
(upbeat music)